In this final lesson, we focused on six different
professions that use genetic information to a different extent
in their day to day jobs. And we've also
looked at the societal implications of having personal genetic
information. Let's see if we can summarize these major
concepts into four main points. Point one, institutional medical
and scientific research has not always been conducted in
ethical ways. Point two, the Genetic Information Nondiscrimination Act was
signed into law in the United States in 2008 to allay fears about the misuse of
personal genetic information. Point three, we've discussed six
different professions that use genetics in their day
to day jobs to a varying degree. For
example, a bioethicist, a computational biologist, a director
of clinical operations, a genetic counselor. A genetic
genealogist, and a human genetics researcher. And Point four,
as the future of personal genetics fast approaches, it's important
that the public understanding of science with regards to this kind
of personal genetics technology advances. If we want to make
ensure that we make the best possible decisions as a society.